ce quia merci nous accordé cette
entrevue bonjour madame
alors c'est parti cette grande
conférence de paris vous y croyez aux
chances de réussite
ce genre d'événements soit défaut la
seule solution mais c'est un élément de
ralliement une solidarité les gens
viennent ici tous ensemble voir ce que
les autres font ils peuvent pas ne pas
faire partie du mouvement pour ne serait
ce que pour cette raison c'est un
élément important
je crois qu'on aura un accord quand même
satisfaisant au terme de la conférence
par la suite on la fait revivre oui il
vous fallait faire vite mais un accord
contraignant à l'herbe cause 2 est quand
même beaucoup de discussions
ouais il faut définir qu'est ce qu'on a
ce qu'on entend par contraignant je
crois que l'ensemble de ce que ce qu'on
entend conclu monsieur hollande prend
tout dans son allocution d'ouverture
on semble aller vers des engagements de
vérification public imputabilité des
dirigeants tous les cinq ans par exemple
pour atteindre la cime faut comprendre
bien sûr que l'important c'est
effectivement il faut que ce soit là
parce que ça peut pas être traité au
sens légal du terme parce que là on perd
les états unis parce que à ce moment là
on fait face à un processus de
ratification au congrès comme vous le
savez c'est très difficile alors de
l'avoir ça c'est essentiel
on parle également beaucoup de
solidarité entre les pays du sud les
pays du nord pour le fonds le fonds des
nations-unies qui est en train d'être
constituée et puis le ralliement la
mobilisation de toutes ces ong qui
pendant des années ont mené à cette
cause là avec plus de succès au début un
peu de gens y croyaient peu de gens les
écoutais est maintenant de se retrouver
bientôt sa maintenance en de l'action si
les trois éléments
vérification solidarité et mobilisation
vous êtes là pour représenter les
intérêts des états fédérés blanche des
juridictions à l'intérieur des pays qui
l'étaient aussi les changements
climatiques
mais quelle peut être la portée de votre
action ici allez très grande l'action du
québec sur la scène internationale sur
cet enjeu du changement climatique
depuis notre arrivée au gouvernement de
multiplier les gestes pour rallier
d'abord l'autre d'autres états fédérés
canadien vous avez lu l'ontario y en a
d'autres qui s'y intéressent nos voisins
américains les chinois que j'ai visités
avait un marché du carbone à shanghai et
six autres endroits qu'ils étaient
abattus le pays sont venus chez nous
pour voir comment fonctionne le marché
du carbone
j'étais au mexique pour rencontrer le
président du mexique et les étoffes et
de l'état fédéral de mexico
ils veulent également avoir des liens
avec nous alors la contribution du
québec c'est pas la seule mais elle est
connue elle est appréciée et pascal est
vraiment vigoureuse et je crois que
c'est ce que les gens veulent entendre
partout maintenant mais c'est pas
aujourd'hui de l'action canadienne va
remonter déployé aujourd'hui on commence
sur la base ce qui était présenté
auparavant par le précédent gouvernement
le grand rendez vous pour le canada pour
nous c'est au retour se réunir pour
déterminer quels sont effectivement
possible pour 2030 quels sont les moyens
d'y parvenir
compte tenu de ce qui a été annoncé et
qu'elle est et 121 sujet épineux quelle
est la contribution de chaque région du
pays pour y parer à l'or donc votre
présence ici en ce moment est-ce que
c'est pas un peu symbolique mais ce trio
a décidé d'inviter tous les premiers
livres autrement dit je crois que c'est
un signe important quand même savez les
symboles le même les symboles sont
importants dans la communication
politique est dans l'action politique
le fait d'avoir deux premiers du canada
avec les populistes quelques quelques
états fédérés ici ça envoie un message
très fort au canada et ailleurs dans le
monde également je crois que c'est à
saluer mais encore une fois l'action et
la réflexion canadienne elle va
commencer surtout après la prépa mais
est-ce que vous pouvez influencer la
position qu'elle va remonter
on a déjà influencé lorsque je me suis
présenté devant les médias est également
à privé avec mes collègues on a rappelé
certains éléments importants d'abord il
faut replacer la marque si vous me
permettez l'expression la marque
canadienne sur cet enjeu de changement
climatique de façon beaucoup plus
positive qu'elle ne l'a été jusqu'à
maintenant redéfinir des filets branding
d'abord le canard 8 un pays producteur
de pétrole mais c'est également
troisième producteur au monde des deux
roues lectrices it et on n'a pas jamais
à l'étranger lorsqu'on parle de notre
pays et son profil énergétique
maintenant avec le nom de l'alberta plus
de 80% de la population canadienne
devrait être dans une juridiction où ils
ont un prix carbone très fort personne
ne sait dans la communauté
internationale
il ya cet effort de redéfinition affaire
est encore une fois cet effort pour être
faite également à l'intérieur du pays et
c'est là que les discussions vont être
assez serré je pourrais cours des
prochains mois avez vous le sentiment
que les positions du précédent
gouvernement
rappelons nuit à la lutte aux
changements climatiques
vous l'avez vu de l'intérieur c'est
envoyer un signal de nos engagements
ça c'est assez dommage pour un pays de
l' influence qu'elle canada mais
heureusement le ton a changé
dès les premières heures de son
gouvernement ce truc doit envoyer un
message très fort sur cette question le
fait qu'il se soit fait accompagner de
province également engagé est un signal
important je crois que vous avez la
réputation du canada les excellentes
dans le monde entier l'a pas été
véritablement modifier sur cet enjeu sur
cette question là effectivement on
arrive on a perdu des plumes on a perdu
des plumes de ce malheureusement de ce
qui semblait pas vraiment soi y croire
entièrement ou soit vouloir entièrement
s'y consacrer par exemple le canada
arrive ici avec les cibles du précédent
du helmand avez vous été consultés dont
le québec utilisent les regrettés
souvent publiquement et en privé les
provinces et territoires n'ont pas été
consultés dans l'élaboration de la cible
canadienne qui rappelons le est une
diminution de 30% mais par rapport à
2005 alors que l'ensemble des pays vous
allez l'entendre dans cette conférence
base de comparaison en général à 1990
donc si on ramène à 1990 on a en fait
annoncé une cible d'environ 14%
ce qui est très inférieur à la cible du
québec pour nancy il ya quelques jours
vous le sentiment de servir un peu dali
geek verbe bons élèves que que le canada
peut montrer dans cette conférence parce
qu'il arrive comme avec un plan beaucoup
moins ambitieux que
c'est certain que pour le canada de
montrer ce que fait le québec c'était
dans la réflexion pour l'image du québec
mais l'ontario également que ces jouets
un marché du carbone
la colombie britannique qui a une taxe
sur le carbone depuis maintenant
plusieurs années ce sont de bons
exemples de bon élève environnementaux
et madame notre lait de l'alberta qui
part de très loin et l'alberta part de
très loin
alors quand même fait un virage qu'il
faut saluer alors oui égale québec mais
également ce mouvement et lille
il est grand au canada je répète plus de
80 % des canadiens dans quelques années
ils vont vivre dans un environnement où
le carbone est tarifé de façon
importante
merci bonne journée madame